[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le lundi 30 octobre voici le programme
la ville de Fontenay-le-Fleury se lance
dans plusieurs grands projets de
rénovation avec notamment l'ouverture
d'une nouvelle halle commercial la
modernisation de son théâtre et de son
cinéma ou encore la création de nouveaux
pots le médico l'objectif redynamiser le
centre-ville nous en parlerons avec le
maire de la commune Richard Rivault il
est notre invité qui dit 31 octobre dit
Halloween pour l'occasion les châteaux
les musées les fermer bien d'autres
lieux encore vous propose une multitude
d'activités et nous vous ferons plonger
dans l'ambiance à travers la découverte
d'une maison hantée notamment du sport
également dans votre sept huit après un
début de saison excellent pour la spoicy
l'aventure s'est terminée hier dimanche
30 octobre lors du septième tour de la
Coupe de France défaite au tir au but
nous ferons l'analyse avec le président
de la es Poissy Olivier sévesc
et donc en plateau avec moi Richard
Rivault bonsoir bonsoir je le rappelle
vous êtes le maire de la commune de
Fontenay-le-Fleury on l'a dit il y a
beaucoup de projets en ce moment pour
redynamiser le centre-ville première
question pourquoi tant de projet d'un
coup
nous n'avions pas de centre-ville alors
c'est pour des raisons historiques la
ville la commune forte croissance entre
les années 60 et 70 et cette croissance
s'est faite dans un secteur on a
maintenant les habitants il y a la
mairie qui arrivait il y a le théâtre
qui est arrivé mais qui s'est éloigné de
ce qui était le centre qu'on s'était un
petit lourd où il y avait une église une
mairie une rue commerçante donc premier
phénomène deuxième phénomène il y a eu
l'arrivée entre les deux des centres
commerciaux où tous les commerces à peu
près de la ville ont disparu et donc on
se retrouvait avec une ville qui était
sans centre-ville donc le projet a
constitué à recréer un centre ville avec
des commerces et des actes et des
activités
avec moi un plateau également Grégory
bonsoir vous allez nous parler de
l'actualité sportive dans les Yvelines
quel est le programme
n'ont pas été terrassés en ce jour
d'halloween on parlera aussi de victoire
une victoire très probetteuse en basket
avec l'Entente Le Chesnay Versailles
c'est du basket féminin et on prendra
des nouvelles aussi de notre rugby woman
préféré Millie Boulard livilloise qui
est en ce moment à la coupe du monde de
rugby avec l'équipe de France et ça se
passe plutôt bien pour elle et pour les
Bleus donc un beau programme en
perspective avant tout ça je vous
propose de faire le point sur la météo
de demain
matin dans les Yvelines vous aurez de
belles éclaircies sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera 12 degrés à Versailles
Mantes-la-Jolie et aux dents du côté de
Rambouillet compter 11 degrés dans
l'après-midi ça devrait rester sec qu'il
fera 15 à 16 degrés en moyenne attention
tout de même météo France annonce des
rafales devant à 65 km/h les Yvelines
sont placées en vigilance jaune
que s'est-il passé dans le département
aujourd'hui quelles sont les choses qui
vont changer en novembre voici les
informations du jour avec Mélanie poquet
un peu moins léger à la pompe elle
devait initialement s'arrêter le premier
novembre la remise gouvernementale sur
le prix des carburants et prolongé 30
centimes d'euros par litre jusqu'au 15
novembre la raison les difficultés
rencontrées par les usagers pour
s'approvisionner le meilleur pain au
chocolat est produit dans les Yvelines
le 29 octobre dernier Michael forchet a
été récompensé lors du premier concours
organisé à l'occasion du Salon du
Chocolat il est au commande de la
boulangerie pâtisserie au soleil à
Poissy le 1er novembre c'est le début de
la trêve hivernale jusqu'au 31 mars 2023
les locataires ne peuvent pas être
expulsés de leur logement sauf exception
côté santé le mois de novembre rime avec
tabac ou plutôt sans tabac ce 1er
novembre le mois sans tabac revient pour
sa septième édition l'opération lançait
en 2016 par santé publique française le
ministère de la Santé de la prévention a
vu s'inscrire plus d'un million de
personnes pour un soutien collectif
réussir à arrêter de fumer pendant 30
jours multiplie par 5 les chances
d'abandonner le tabac définitivement il
est on met 42e au classement ATP mais
surtout premier Français Arthur
hinderlech est le mieux classé devant
Adrian manarino 43e également fils 46e
livelinois profite de l'absence sur les
cours de gaine mon fils et gagne 9
places au classement grâce à son
parcours jusqu'en quart de finale au
tournoi de balle
et comme d'habitude si vous avez vu une
information ou quelque chose qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
réagir en utilisant le hashtag 78 news
on en parlait il y a quelques instants
la ville de Fontenay-le-Fleury
redynamise son centre-ville Richard
Rivault donc où je vous représente une
nouvelle fois vous êtes le maire de la
commune de Fontenay-le-Fleury alors ça a
commencé cette redynamisation par la
création d'un pôle médical en 2017 et là
vous allez de nouveau accroître votre
votre pôle médical avec la création du
coup bientôt en 2023 les travaux
débutants 2023 c'est bien ça les travaux
vont commencer en début d'année et
effectivement on va accroître on va
rajouter 5 cabinets pour pouvoir
accueillir des médecins je pense
beaucoup de villes ont cette
problématique les médecins vieillissent
partent à la retraite il y a eu un
humérus dans les années précédentes qui
a fait qu'on a moins de médecins qui
arrivent et donc dans une ville comme la
nôtre il nous manque deux ce sera des
nouveaux médecins ce sont des nouveaux
médecins
de nouveaux médecins qui arrivent sans
patientèle et pour les faire venir il
leur faut des locaux adaptés parce que
avant le médecin vous l'avez peut-être
connu vous pouvez vous recevoir dans un
appartement mais tout ça c'est plus
possible aujourd'hui ce que c'est pas
habilité PMR donc nous on leur fait des
locaux de plain-pied dans lesquelles
peuvent venir s'installer avoir un
contrat avec la ville et être en plus
ensemble parce que maintenant les
médecins préfèrent être regroupés donc
on aura finalement un pôle médical dans
lequel on vise de nouveau médecin un ou
deux spécialistes nouveau plus les 15
que nous avons déjà ça fera en
centre-ville une belle capacité pour
accueillir et apporter de la médecine
aux habitants
c'est un contrat avec la ville ça veut
dire qu'ils vont être salariés
directement par la ville de
Fontenay-le-Fleury contrat juste de
location c'est vraiment le la formule la
plus simple ils viennent on en met à
disposition un local ils ont un bail
avec la ville et c'est nous le bailleur
ce qui nous permet de faire des prix
compétitifs parce que c'est aussi
important pour eux et ça leur apporte
une certaine liberté parce qu'on a vu
dans les maisons médicales avant ils se
regrouper ils achetaient une maison
médicale à 7 ou 8 et ce qu'on a vu avec
le départ d'un certain nombre de
médecins c'est que la maison médicale
s'est retrouvée en difficulté aux étés 8
ou 10 pour la porter ils se retrouvait à
quatre ou six et obligé de la fermer
donc là on a une formule où la ville
porte ce risque là et eux ils ont un
contrat très simple ils peuvent rester
là toute leur vie dans les prochaines
années vous allez aussi construire un
nouvel EHPAD un EHPAD est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus c'est
également combien ça va coûter ou est-ce
qu'il sera situé alors on aura un nouvel
EHPAD qui va arriver rue Descartes à
Fontenay-le-Fleury alors ça sera en
bordure de pleine de Versailles c'est un
EHPAD alors ce qu'on appelle un
transfert ce qu'aujourd'hui on a plus le
droit de faire de nouveaux EHPAD il y a
une capacité au globale en Île-de-France
qui est satisfaisante donc il y a pas de
nouvelles épates possible par contre à
Viroflay il y avait un EHPAD qui était
très ancien très vétuste et ça coûtait
beaucoup plus cher de le réhabiliter que
d'en créer un nouveau donc il va être
créé à Fontenay avec deux apports de
service complémentaires on va pouvoir y
accueillir des personnes qui sont
frappées de maladies cognitive de type
Alzheimer on crée un département et on
aura un département pour les personnes
porteuses de handicap donc on aura un
EHPAD qui est au total pour accueillir
150 personnes la ville de Fontenay met à
disposition le terrain à l'euro
symbolique alors c'est un projet
totalement public
le département
et l'hôpital public vont financer la
construction et ça sera agréé par la RS
pour qu'on fait ça parce que nous avons
choisi d'avoir un EHPAD public pour que
tout le monde puisse y aller si
aujourd'hui vous allez dans un EHPAD
privé si vous avez une très belle
retraite vous pouvez dépenser 4500 euros
par mois pour y aller si par contre vous
êtes quelqu'un avec des revenus je
dirais médian normaux et bien vous
pouvez pas aller dans ce type
d'institution nous ce qu'on vise là
c'est un EHPAD public avec un coût
journalier à 75 euros c'est vraiment la
cible du projet ce qui va permettre à
quelqu'un qui est au minimum vieillesse
plus la PA d'être accueilli autrement
dit cet état là pourra accueillir toutes
les populations ce qui correspond bien à
une ville de Fontenay où on a bien sûr
des cadres supérieurs mais on a aussi
une partie de notre population qui
touche les minima sociaux et donc on
voulait absolument un état public
en 2025 là l'architecte est désigné le
permis va être déposé cette année on
devrait avoir les débuts des travaux en
2023 alors et une ouverture si tout va
bien dès qu'on parle de travaux vous
faites prudent mais effectivement en fin
d'année 2025 un autre projet phare pour
redynamiser le centre-ville c'est la
création de cette nouvelle halle
commerciale qui a vu le jour
tout simplement c'était nécessaire cette
halle pour redynamiser le centre-ville
alors déjà pour une raison qui est
simple quand on veut un centre ville qui
vit il y a le mot vivre dedans il faut
de la vie et quand vous regardez
finalement ce qu'est un marché tel qu'il
était à fond de Fleury moi c'est ce que
j'appelle une boîte noire c'est à dire
que vous avez une structure qui est là
elle fonctionne trois matinées par
semaine le reste du temps les portes
sont fermées et elle est éteinte donc il
y a pas de vie dans un marché donc notre
marché qui datait les années 70 on a
pris le pari de le transformer en Halles
commerciales avec un concept qui est
finalement assez simple
vous entrez dans la halle par une porte
elle va être finalement un tout petit
peu en retrait et sur toute la façade
vous avez des commerces et des commerces
du quotidien donc on a une boulangerie
qui va arriver alors une fois sonnerie
un traiteur italien et une brasserie ça
paraît tout simple quand on dit ça mais
faire ça ça a pris beaucoup de temps on
a on a commencé ce projet la
construction 2019 mais à la première
partie qui vient de s'achever celle qui
accueille des commerçants du marché la
deuxième partie l'aménagement des
cellules commerciales est en cours avec
des commerçants qui vont ouvrir entre le
mois de novembre et le mois de janvier
et là il y a une grande différence c'est
que au lieu d'avoir cette boîte qui
était fermée on aura une halle
commerciale avec des commerces ouverts
tous les jours un service du quotidien
et qui va donner une occasion
Fontenaysiens de venir et de revenir
dans une ville comme la nôtre une
boulangerie qui fonctionne peut attirer
entre 600 et 800 clients jours
ces commerciaux on le sait dans dans un
contexte où le commerce a tendance à
fuir plutôt les centres-villes avec
l'émergence de grandes structures
commerciales à côté des des centres
commerciaux c'est pas trop difficile de
alors
c'est un peu l'appréhension qu'on aurait
pu avoir et qu'on avait très honnêtement
au début du projet c'est beaucoup
intéressant est-ce qu'on va dans la
bonne direction parce qu'on a engagé
quand même beaucoup d'argent public dans
cette opération le réaménagement du
centre-ville le réaménagement complet
avec l'assise et le jardin c'est 10
millions d'euros donc oui c'est quand
même pour apporter du service ça fait
réfléchir quand même et bien finalement
je vais vous apporter la réponse c'est
comme pour le pôle médical on n'avait
pas fini le projet qu'on avait plus de
candidats pour chacune des cellules
qu'on pouvait offrir de place et on a dû
finalement organiser un mini concours et
refuser des commerçants et là on voit
bien tous les commerçants parce que
c'est les commerçants qui vont porter
l'aménagement des cellules et bien ils
sont en train de les aménager et ils
viennent et on a finalement aucune
difficulté à remplir la le commercial et
pour une raison très simple quand vous
allez chercher votre pain vous allez pas
aller chez Leclerc ici parce que c'est
la grande surface la plus proche vous
allez pas faire 4 km et prendre votre
voiture c'est quand même agréable que de
descendre à pied de venir en
centre-ville d'acheter son pain c'est
agréable d'aller prendre un café de
prendre le temps de discuter avec avec
des amis des gens que vous rencontrez
donc en fait ce que vous apportez dans
un centre-ville c'est de la vie du
quotidien que vous n'allez pas trouver
dans une grande surface vous met au défi
d'aller prendre un café dans une grande
surface même s'ils ont une cafétéria
c'est pas très sympa alors que dans un
environnement avec des gens que vous
connaissez vous allez passer un bon
moment et c'est ce pari là qu'on fait ce
pari de l'expérience de vie du quotidien
agréable convivial et justement nous
sommes allés interroger les fantasiens
sur leur nouveau marché voici ce qu'ils
en pensent écouter
moi je trouve ça vraiment agréable par
rapport à ce qu'il y avait avant ou
c'était vraiment beaucoup plus petit là
c'est c'est très joli c'est bien rénové
puis du coup c'est plus accueillant et
ça donne plus envie de venir je trouve
que les stands sont un petit peu petits
et on est obligé d'escalader pour
choisir les fruits et légumes et c'est
quand même bien moi je viens à pied je
fais mes courses tous les voilà tout le
temps ici en fait les fruits légumes du
local le centre des lait maintenant ça
commence à devenir dynamique après il y
a le changement des clients il y a des
clients qu'on n'a jamais vu avant ça
ramène des nouvelles clientèle il y a du
bien mais il y a quand même au niveau de
du positionnement du rayonnage
et puis du passage parce que le passage
entre les entre les les étalages et très
trop juste j'irai s'il fallait noter je
mettrai une note de 7 sur 10
7 sur 10 Richard rivaux ça va c'est
acceptable
mais ce qui est important c'est ce que
vous avez entendu et c'est vrai que on
est dans un chemin où on a choisi
finalement la qualité vous avez un
micro-trottoir qui l'a très bien dit ses
qualités et aussi on s'est inspiré des
autres expériences donc on a fait je le
fais personnellement avec
avant de prendre la décision on a été
voir ce qui se faisait ailleurs dans des
endroits où ça fonctionne
c'était plutôt agréable j'ai fait
Barcelone Lisbonne Londres et on a été
voir ces marchés qui fonctionnent et on
s'est rendu compte que ils avaient un
point commun c'est que des grands grands
étals comme on avait qui fonctionnait en
mode libre service avant de vous étiez
dans le marché de Fontenay vous rentrez
vous prenez votre panier vous êtes le
tour des rayons vous sortez à la caisse
bien démarcher qui fonctionne c'est pas
ça c'est un marché avec des étals plus
resserré et sur lequel vous une
interaction avec le commerçant il vous
explique le produit et c'est ce pari là
qu'on a fait donc on a été rencontré les
commerçants on a discuté avec eux on a
pris un concepteur des étals et on a
changé la configuration alors il y a
j'en conviens un point qui est un peu
différent c'est que si c'est pas le
commerce en qui nous sert vous avez des
produits qui sont un peu haut à accéder
on nous fait cette observation oui parce
que je ça a été conçu pour que le
commerçants servent de clients et pas
que le client se serve et on est encore
dans cette phase de mutation où on avait
un marché où les clients se servaient
vers un marché où on retrouve cette
interaction du commerçant qui sert le
client alors rapidement Richard Rivault
parce qu'on est un peu pris par le temps
un autre grand projet c'est la
modernisation du théâtre et du cinéma
qui est en cours est-ce que quels sont
les travaux qui sont qui sont en train
d'être réalisés et quel est le budget là
aussi
ces travaux c'est un bâtiment de 1980
donc on adresse à transition énergétique
donc il faut l'isoler complètement pour
avoir la performance d'un bâtiment
d'aujourd'hui ça c'est une composante du
projet deuxième composant peut-être à
une composante que vous allez mieux
comprendre on est dans un environnement
technique quand on est dans un théâtre
alors c'est à dire technique parce que
vous accueillez des spectateurs donc il
faut des sièges des marches tout ça
dater de 1980 des marches qui étaient un
peu trop hautes des sièges qui étaient
d'origine donc tout ça était un peu
vieux puis vous avez toute la partie
technique celle qui est derrière ou les
techniciens bon bah ils vont installer
un décor ils vont le défaire on avait
rien de numérique on avait des choses
avec des moteurs électromécaniques avec
des manivelets pour changer le décor
donc entre deux spectacles parfois il
fallait quatre jours pour changer de
décor avec la transformation qu'on va
faire pour la même opération il faudra 4
heures on va finalement transporter ce
théâtre et ce cinéma dans le monde
moderne d'aujourd'hui et dans le monde
du numérique où on pourra aujourd'hui
recevoir des spectacles du monde entier
et bien merci Richard et vous d'être
venu en plateau avec nous pour parler de
tous ces grands projets on va passer
maintenant à l'autre partie de notre
émission l'actualité c'est aussi
Halloween cette année encore France
Miniature donne rendez-vous aux familles
pour découvrir de nombreuses activités
durant toutes les vacances de la
Toussaint le reportage de Julien Leroy
et Patrick Jacques
[Musique]
de passe des choses étranges France
Miniature le Gendarme de Saint-Tropez
les trois mousquetaires ou encore les
rois de France se sont invités sur le
parc pour Halloween ils ont amené avec
eux de l'au-delà quelques copains et des
décors aussi amusants que terrifiants on
voit des squelettes des chauves-souris
des toiles d'araignées jusqu'au 6
novembre c'est dans ce décor que les
visiteurs pourront découvrir ou
redécouvrir la France et ses monuments
en miniature c'est une belle initiative
d'avoir un tel en
patrimoine français on nous donne la
visiter en une journée avec la
possibilité de faire cette découverte et
donc c'est plutôt une très belle balade
familiale et une belle un bon moment de
l'histoire à la visite s'ajoute des
activités spéciales Halloween les
familles pourront se tester autour d'un
jeu de piste et d'énigmes dans le but de
retrouver les bijoux dérobés de la reine
aliénos de la citrouille on se plaît à
découvrir les questions et à se
réinterroger notre culture générale au
programme également des jeux l'in
incontournable distribution de bonbons
et des animations
à France Miniature Halloween fait partie
des temps forts de la vie du parc depuis
maintenant quelques années on peut pas
faire des vacances de la Toussaint sans
une animation Halloween et du coup
chaque année on a vraiment avec des
nouveaux décors on va trouver cette
année des personnages un peu typiques
dans les régions de France avec des
costumes assez sordides pour certains
mais on reste vraiment sur du rigolo
effrayant alors
oserez-vous vous aventurer au parc pour
Halloween
Halloween c'était aussi au manoir du
Haras national des Bréviaires petits et
grands sont venus se faire peur Julien
Leroy a réussi à pénétrer dans la maison
hantée regardez
[Musique]
vous pénétrer dans la maison hantée de
la famille Calavera la compagnie Pixum
avait investi le manoir du Haras
national des Bréviaires pour Halloween
petits et grands étaient invités à
déambuler à travers les pièces et
interagir avec des personnages
effrayants on les emmène dans une
aventure avec nous où ils vont déambuler
dans le château et découvrir des décors
très détaillés on est dans un cabinet de
curiosité géant
ça faisait assez peur je suis surtout au
début quand le quand l'homme nous
accueillait dans la maison du style très
coloré du dia des los muertos mexicain à
l'esthétique edwardienne du début du 20e
siècle de ce mène et une trentaine de
personnes auront été nécessaires à
l'installation de ce spectacle immersif
intitulé La maison hantée
parce que notre projet c'est de faire du
théâtre écolo donc on fait que de
l'objet de récup on achète très très peu
d'éléments de décor et on est en
partenariat avec eux pour faire de la
barre d'organisation artistique de leurs
produits et nous on fait nos
valorisation écologique de notre projet
en même temps donc c'est donnant donnant
avec eux
quelqu'un voudrait une petite coupe une
coupe de cheveux non le travail des
comédiens mais les canevas narratifs et
improvisation lors des échanges avec le
public j'ai beaucoup aimé
l'interactivité avec les avec les
comédiens le fait que ils embarque à la
fois les enfants et les et les adultes
avec des décors fabuleux de très beaux
costumes et des animations riches sur
évidemment le thème Halloween environ
1200 spectateurs ont fait le déplacement
pendant les trois soirées organisées
fort de ce succès la compagnie Pixum
envisage de renouveler l'expérience
macabre l'année prochaine
et nous serons au rendez-vous à l'année
prochaine c'est l'heure maintenant de
notre seconde partie d'émission avec
l'actualité sportive
et c'est avec vous Grégory on le disait
en début d'émission en tennis livelinois
Arthur rite darkley le premier joueur
français au classement ATP mais
l'actualité sportive c'est aussi du
rugby de qui va-t-on parler un peu plus
simple
bien évidemment et de l'équipe de France
de rugby féminin les Bleus sont en
demi-finale de la Coupe du monde qui se
dispute actuellement en Nouvelle-Zélande
samedi en quart de finale à wangaray
elle longtemps porté avec la manière
contre l'Italie victoire 39 à 3 5 essais
inscrits par la France aucun par Emily
Boulard notre yvelinoise a été tout de
même désigné MVP du match c'est-à-dire
meilleur joueuse l'arrière a été en
grande forme c'est notamment de sa belle
relance de 60 mètres en début de
rencontre qui est parti le premier essai
français marqué par Johanna agrisé bravo
elle bravo au bleu samedi les
coéquipiers d'Emily Boulard feront face
aux pays haute les blackfirns de la
Nouvelle-Zélande une rencontre dans le
mythique parc d'Auckland et l'autre
demi-finale opposera Mathilde
l'Angleterre au Canada et on continue
avec du football Grégory avec notre
invité oui il s'agit d'Olivier sébésuc
bonsoir bonsoir président de l'AS Poissy
club de football alors on va parler avec
vous de bonne nouvelle le très bon début
de saison de lace Poissy votre club en
National 2 mais aussi et d'abord de ce
résultat très frustrant qui est arrivé
ce weekend c'est l'élimination a
peut-être voir l'animation s'afficher et
l'élimination de votre club au septième
tour de la Coupe de France une défaite
au tir au but 6 à 5 contre Oissel un
club de Seine-Maritime de Nationale 3 il
y avait eu un partout à l'issue du temps
réglementaire leurs conséquences plus
aucun club yvelinois en Coupe de France
après 7 tours on rappelle que Versailles
qui s'était il sait jusqu'au demi-finale
l'an passé a été éliminé dès le 6e tour
deux jours après cette élimination dans
quel état d'esprit êtes-vous est-ce que
vous êtes déçu après cette élimination
Olivier très clair avec vous je suis
anéanti
triste j'ai été très très affecté par
cette défaite pourquoi parce que je
rêvais je rêvais comme un vrai passionné
de football que qu'on puisse
effectivement que vous l'avez signalé
tout à l'heure
Jean-Luc Arribart qui est un de mes amis
était arrivé avec avec Versailles en
demi-finale l'année dernière évidemment
que moi un peu plus d'humilité je
voulais pas arriver finale mais une
espèce de rêve puisqu'il y avait un
parcours la preuve le club que l'on a
joué qui nous ont battu m3 joueront
contre une D1 je sais pas si vous
imaginez
peut-être il y avait peut-être quelque
chose pour le club quand on sait que des
clubs comme le mien on se bat sur sur
des aspects financiers et on sait que la
Coupe de France peut amener
effectivement un petit peu pour les
joueurs mais surtout pour le club car un
club n'est pas que la Nationale 2
d'avoir une c'est une grosse sections
féminine des enfants etc 900 licenciés
pour moi après la perte d'un certain
nombre de sponsors l'année dernière et
les gros d'ailleurs des institutionnels
c'est un rêve aussi de de cette Coupe de
France c'est très bien que je me voyais
de tous les possibles
avec l'ensemble des dirigeants etc on en
parlait on a touché du doigt une espèce
de rêve qui permet aux jeunes de rêver
aux joueurs aux dirigeants au Président
je suis un gamin quelque part et c'est
quoi le plus frustrant c'est de perdre
contre une équipe vous l'avez dit N3
donc c'est une équipe qui était une
division en dessous vous l'avez dit dans
le tour suivant vous auriez pu jouer une
équipe
si jamais facile en tant que joueur je
l'ai connu j'étais président du nid une
toute petite division nous avions
éliminé le National
néanmoins voilà dans la semaine je n'ai
pas vu les joueurs je n'ai pas eu le
coach mais je pensais qu'ils étaient
ultra motivés parce que j'avais fixé un
petit peu les objectifs pour le club je
répète pour la notoriété pour la ville
pour
chavouer de se faire plaisir à tout le
monde bien sûr j'étais fier de ça on a
vécu des moments difficiles dernièrement
des licenciements de garçons sur des
erreurs il y a eu peut-être petit
problème et vraiment je vous laisse
cette dynamique je moi personnellement
je peux vous dire que
samedi soir et dimanche mes enfants
m'ont vu anéanti je le suis encore alors
j'ai le travail j'ai la famille des
choses beaucoup plus graves et vous le
savez d'origine ukrainienne l'actualité
fait que néanmoins moi je suis je suis
frustré mais vous l'avez dit on a aussi
le championnat joue on avait très bien
démarré et dans un instant je vous en
prie mais là oui je suis un garçon
touché ouais et si on rappelle juste le
scénario du match vous étiez mené 1-0
après 20 minutes de jeu Poissy est
revenu au score sur penalty à 26e minute
de jeu finalement s'en est resté là il y
a eu un partout à l'issue du temps
réglementaire des fêtes au tir au but 6
à 5 vous allez utiliser le mot motiver
ils étaient pas assez motivés ou ils
avaient pas senti investi de c'est pas
ce que j'ai dit c'est l'heure du match
je dirais que on va pas rentrer dans
tous les détails techniques du football
néanmoins on avait deux deux garçons qui
qui n'étaient pas là et non des moindres
le gardien titulaire qui est un garçon
qui a été quand même au centre de
formation du PSG qu'on a été chercher
les dernières un élément numéro 6
importants alors je dis pas que les
remplaçants mais peut-être qu'il fait la
différence c'est 400 tonnes de clubs
c'est que quand vous n'avez pas les
moyens vous n'avez pas un bon très
profond mais je considère que quand on
est remplaçant pas je l'ai été en tant
que joueur on doit prendre sa place et
la Coupe de France c'est se transcender
vous savez ces couleurs là c'est ça et
là j'ai trouvé une équipe assez
apathique Bron très beaucoup moins
motivé que les matchs que j'ai pu voir
le parcours a été bon en Coupe de France
on rappelle vous êtes trop au quatrième
tour Nationale 2 il y a eu deux clubs de
régional une c'est le plus haut niveau
régional qui ont été éliminés au dernier
tour vous éliminer Sainte-Geneviève qui
est une équipe qui évolue comme vous en
National 2 il y a eu un bon parcours
absolument mais j'étais très fier
d'ailleurs et on avait commis je pense
que peut-être que certains se sont vu
beaux du fait d'avoir d'être arrivé à ce
stade là et on connaissait déjà et on
connaissait le tirage d'après donc
peut-être que sur 10 on va se retrouver
en 32e de finale moi aussi d'ailleurs
voilà l'histoire est terminée une de
plus depuis 6 ans que je suis au club
malheureusement j'aurais jamais réussi à
aller un peu plus loin que 7e tour et
dernière éliminé par Versailles mais
après ils ont mis le parcours là si je
vois par exemple en 32e de finale parce
que le Oissel va recevoir cette cette D1
si on voit par exemple un wacel PSG je
peux vous dire que les larmes vont me
couler moi qui suis abonné passionné
ancien genre du PSG je je rêvais pour
nous par exemple PSG va venir impossible
il aurait pu être une Ligue 2 et c'est
non vraiment je suis il y a la déception
7e tour alors il y a quand même et ça il
y a du positif
avec un très bon début de saison en
championnat de l'AS Poissy on va voir
aussi l'animation sachet avec le
classement de cette poule A de National
2 18 points pour les poissons soit
seulement trois points de moins que le
leader Rouen d'autant que vous comptez
un match en moins en plus par rapport à
Rouen et après huit journée vous avez
joué 7 matchs pour votre part il y a 6
victoires dont une contre Rouen le
leader je le disais et une seule défaite
c'était face à Saint-Malo lors de la 5e
journée le bilan est quand même
satisfaisant sur ce début de saison même
si à cette élimination amer en Coupe de
France oui oui tout à fait c'est vrai
que en début de saison les articles que
vous pouvez lire ici ou là sur sur
l'effectif que l'on avait on avait quand
même perdu quelques joueurs quelques de
qualité aussi on a reconstruit des
jeunes des profils c'est le staff avec
moi l'ensemble de mon bureau qui avons
choisi c'est certains joueurs la
mayonnaise a pris donc il y avait cette
dynamique elle est encore là d'ailleurs
puisque à un moment donné je suis là
aussi pour dire un certain c'est vrai
que je suis triste mais c'est pas dans
la nature de de baisser les bras
j'espère que les joueurs vont prendre
conscience que avec un match en moins et
des matchs qui arrivent et bien on peut
on peut je l'espère en tout cas parce
qu'il y a un maintien vous savez qu'il y
a 5 voire 6 clubs qui descend qui
descendent et là en début de saison
compte tenu de la qualité du groupe vous
retrouvez aujourd'hui effectivement à
deux points du premier les joueurs ont
fait du très très bon travail avec le
staff je les en félicite bon la Coupe de
France et voilà on explique juste il y a
toute une révolution dans le monde du
football français avec des équipes d'un
nombre d'équipes qui diminue par
division c'est le cas aussi dans les
championnats supérieurs tout à fait
seulement 4 montées mais c'était déjà le
cas pour les quatre poules de National 2
et on peut aller jusqu'à 6 décembre
effectivement sur cette saison mais du
coup c'est quoi l'objectif parce que les
quatre derniers peuvent descendre dans
votre pool vous êtes troisième pas loin
du premier est-ce que vous y pensez à la
monter ou
fixer l'objectif mais franchement vous
connaissez car le livre qui met en place
il y a 6 ans football et me dit tu faut
que de toute façon tu valides le
maintien rapidement on est pas mal parti
mais il faut être sur une bonne
dynamique cette Coupe de France nous
fasse pas mal je pense prochain match
très rapidement et on s'en va jouer à
Chateaubriant on vous souhaite tout le
meilleur pour cette saison on va suivre
la suite des événements avec attention
avec ce très bon début de saison malgré
l'élimination ce week-end en Coupe de
France merci Olivier c'est les yeux et
bonne soirée merci du football encore
Grégory on va parler au niveau
départemental avec le championnat de
division une de Dick strict le voisin FC
recevait ou euh so à l'occasion de la
cinquième journée en retard de ce
championnat dans une rencontre à sens
unique elle est VICE Chinois se sont
largement imposées beaucoup de buts dans
cette rencontre regardez le résumé avec
les images de Julien Leroy hiérarchie
respectée Voisins-le-Bretonneux
accueillait ce dimanche 30 octobre le
sport olympique de Houilles dernier du
championnat de division
dans ce match en retard de la cinquième
journée les vicinois auront mis moins de
20 minutes pour marquer sur une erreur
de relance des eaux-villois le numéro 11
de voisins profite d'une bonne remise de
son coéquipier pour ouvrir le score
[Applaudissements]
5 minutes plus tard ça fait déjà 2-0
pour les locaux un premier tir repoussé
par la barre transversale le numéro 10
n'a plus qu'à pousser la balle au fond
des filets il inscrit même un double et
quelques minutes avant la fin de la
première période bien lancée dans le dos
de la défense de Houilles voisin mène
3-0 à la mi-temps
[Applaudissements]
on a la première grosse occasion qui
peut créer à la différence et échanger
l'atmosphère du match après sur deux
contrats qu'on prend deux buts pendant
qu'ils n'ont pas contre le corps du jeu
c'était assez équilibré ce qui nous
manque un peu dedans s'il est galvanisé
en même temps on a fait une super
première mi-temps clairement il y a pas
photo on mène 3-0 à la mi-temps et le
match il était presque tué et après on
fait un mauvais début de deuxième
effectivement où il démarre mieux la
seconde période des l'entame l'équipe
récupère le ballon au milieu et surprend
voisin le Bretonneux une réalisation du
numéro 10 auvillois pour réduire le
score 3-1 mais les vicinois ne végètent
pas longtemps et inscrivent un quatrième
but à l'heure de jeu d'une frappe lourde
du numéro 7 à l'entrée de la surface où
il sera même réduit à 10 après un coup
de sang de l'un de ses joueurs bien
évidemment expulsé par l'arbitre après
quelques instants de tension à 10
minutes du terme voisin le Bretonneux
enfonce le clou un but marqué au terme
d'une belle action collective très space
conclut par le numéro 8
score final 5 1 pour le v
c'est une victoire qui nous fait du bien
parce que c'était un match en retard on
est bien on a fait une préparation
compliquée et au final on est à trois
victoires une défaite donc on est on est
en haut du classement et on a un mois de
novembre très compliqué qui nous attend
donc c'est à nous de faire le boulot
maintenant on est prêt on est sur une
tendance ou une spirale très très
mauvaise très très négative il faut vite
qu'on change la spirale pour pouvoir
enchaîner des résultats positifs sachant
que dans ce championnat rien n'est perdu
il suffit d'enchaîner deux trois
résultats positifs pour se retrouver
là-haut donc nous on va rien lâcher on
va travailler on va pousser pour
enchaîner les résultats positifs grâce à
ce succès voisin grimpe à la quatrième
place du classement et revient à trois
points du leader Limay oui et toujours
lanterne rouge prochaine journée
dimanche 6 novembre
Hermine avec du basket Grégory plus
précisément samedi l'entente Le Chesnay
Versailles 78 accueillait Dieppe pour le
compte de la sixième journée de
Nationale 2 féminine après avoir été
mené les illinoises ont gagné retour sur
le match cette fois-ci avec les images
de Gabriel Gontier
une victoire au caractère pour l'Entente
Le Chesnay Versailles contre Dieppe se
succède dans la sixième journée de
Nationale 2 n'a pourtant pas été simple
à obtenir d'entrée de jeu les
yvelinoises encaisse un 10-0 après un
premier temps mort l'ulcv se remet peu à
peu en ordre de marche le club compte
jusqu'à 12 longueurs de retard mais
parvient à revenir à moins de points de
son adversaire à la fin du deuxième
carton le chêne Versailles est mené 34
32 à la pose
et tout ça mais en fait on a commencé le
match en travers on traverse ça et mais
on voit que le coach il a pris le temps
mort on s'est remis dedans et on est
sorti sur le parquet combien avec une
autre esprit je leur ai dit qu'il faut
qu'on croit
sur nous
et qu'il faut qu'il faut se battre
jusqu'au bout parce qu'on a possibilité
de gagner cette équipe dans le troisième
carton radunovic chez Galise le LCV
prend définitivement l'ascendant sur la
rencontre l'équipe est bien en place et
Cruse progressivement son avance de 14
points les joueuses ne tremblent pas
dans le quatrième carton quant à 3
minutes de la fin Dieppe revient
seulement à 4 unités le chêne Versailles
s'impose bien le score final 60 à 53
quatrième succès de la saison pour le
club c'était vraiment une victoire
d'équipe on a été la chercher avec le
mental et parce que voilà quand on gagne
de 14 points et qu'elle revienne à 4
points et qui reste 3 minutes là c'est
mentalement on n'est pas on est pas
solide c'est là on peut tomber dans la
défaite et vraiment c'est la réaction
d'équipe qu'il faut retenir ce soir
après un mauvais départ on a su se
remettre dedans
on a bien défendu sur ce match là contre
une belle équipe qui vise la montée on a
encaissé 53 points les Yvelines sont
actuellement
2 c'est la meilleure défense du groupe
avec 321 points conseils depuis le début
de la saison prochain match samedi 5
novembre face au leader
Villeneuve-d'Ascq merci beaucoup Grégory
merci à vous c'est bientôt la fin de
cette émission mais je vous propose
qu'on jette un petit coup d'oeil à la
météo avant de se quitter
demain matin dans les Yvelines vous
aurez de belles éclaircies sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures il fera 12 degrés à
Versailles Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan du
côté de Rambouillet compter 11 degrés ça
devrait rester sec dans l'après-midi
également il fera 15 à 16 degrés en
moyenne attention tout de même météo
France annonce des rafales de vent à 65
km/h les Yvelines sont placées en
vigilance jaune et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi jusqu'au
bout avec nous je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]